Oh danced chewy flavorless old fever hi
I'm Alexis and I'm always up for a
challenge that's why I've taken to the
Internet to decide what appliance I
should use to make a three-course meal
at the end a surprise guest will come on
and they'll have to guess what I used to
cook with we've gone through the
comments from our previous episodes and
you've chosen what I'm gonna use let's
check it out
not bad not bad
this feels like the most closest thing
to actually cooking that I've used so
far that's that I haven't used a toaster
oven and like over a decade so who knows
back in the early days of tasty they had
a really small kitchen and they were
just using toaster ovens so if they can
do it so can i right so my producer is
graciously let me do a bit of research
we know how it went when I didn't get
you last time so Oh
let me see what they have to say toaster
ovens have a lot of hot spots so it's
really important to rotate the pan as
you're going really good tip probably
wouldn't done it hey check this out huh
okay they have a broiled that's big this
goes
[Music]
okay feels good I've chosen my recipes I
feel like I have kind of a handle on how
this works it's gonna be challenging but
I think I have some good ideas I'm
pretty excited so I'm starting off with
dessert I'm making strawberry shortcake
I've made it four times than I can count
I actually made these biscuits for a
tasty 101 about grilled desserts and
they're really easy they're really great
so that's not really what worries me I
know it goes up to 450° which is amazing
that's all I need but I'm just kind of
skeptical that this is gonna get an even
baked all the way through so first
things first I'm gonna preheat the
toaster oven I'm adding two cups of
flour quarter cup of sugar teaspoon of
salt little salt actually helps enhance
the flavor and will actually make it
sweeter and more delicious two
tablespoons of baking powder
so just whisk it all together look how
easy this is I've got frozen butter here
and I'm gonna grade it with a cheese
grater this is a really easy way to get
it evenly combined with the flour and
then you just toss it adding the milk
could also use buttermilk combined it to
make this kind of shaggy dough one of
the perks is that it doesn't have to
rest you're just gonna fold it over a
few times that's gonna create layers
five or six times is enough more than
that is actually gonna kind of like
squash the butter okay so this is a
really fun protip fun for me so if you
dip your cookie cutter in some flour
press down and then take it immediately
up so no twisting it'll actually help
prevent the layers from getting smushed
and create like a really airy biscuit
I'm gonna brush them with a little bit
of milk the milk is just gonna give them
a glossy finish on top you could use
heavy cream you could do an egg wash and
then I'm just gonna sprinkle a little
bit of sugar on top
that's a nice texture that's a little
sweetness okay these look really good
I'm gonna bake it for six minutes and
internet reminded me to flip it halfway
I'm going to
that and then see what happens well my
biscuits baked I'm gonna work on
macerating my strawberries so they get
nice and flavorful I'm just gonna add
sugar to the strawberries so we're just
gonna break them down over a few hours
and make them soft and juicy I'm gonna
add some lemon zest and juice just to
add a bit of acidity I think in order to
really elevate this and kind of WoW and
surprise my taste testers I should add
balsamic to its a few drops I don't want
it to be overwhelmingly sweet like
saccharine sweet I just want it to be I
wanted to taste like my birthday when I
was five just had too much to ask
okay the biscuits look like they're
getting pretty brown on top that looks
fairly raw okay they're fully wrong the
middle so or time I think this could be
one of the downsides of a toaster oven
is that it's so hot that the top is
getting kind of scorched and the middle
isn't fully cooking but you know I don't
want to make judgments too soon might be
5 because the toaster oven is my only
appliance I need to whip cream by hand
here we go again
oh the biscuits look like they're
getting really dark maybe it's okay well
honestly it looks beautiful it looks
like fluffy and light right wait it's a
little touch-and-go at the temperature
but they are obviously perfect done one
thing hmm for my second course I'm going
to make a skirt steak with crispy
potatoes and a blue cheese compound
butter usually if I was making breasts
potatoes I would parboil them and water
before it's obviously not option so I've
got to cook them raw hard boiling just
helps make the inside really light and
fluffy and the exterior really crispy
hopefully I can achieve that by
completely omit any stuff I'm going to
cut my potatoes into smaller parts so
they will take less time rosemary
easy easy easy salt and pepper I'm just
gonna toss it together look beautiful
beautiful beautiful well when this heats
up these will be ready to go in the
meantime I'm gonna make a blue cheese
try of compound butter and a compound
butter is basically just infusing butter
with other flavors chilling it I love
blue cheese I love all cheese like yes
it is pungent you know I think people
get afraid of things because of certain
lengths Mallos or it's like oh that's
weird it's mold
but like spoiler all cheese's mold I was
just gonna you know kind of mash this up
but my butter looks a little stiff
so maybe if I just put it on top of the
toaster oven it'll melt a little
this was so smart so smart it's like the
perfect consistency I love to his Romans
who knew that it really incorporated so
that the flavors everywhere and you're
not just taking like one big bite of
bleu cheese and then a bite of butter
and then I'm gonna roll it into a log
okay see it doesn't look great yeah but
if you kind of fold it down beautiful
I'm gonna give these potatoes a try huh
it's really nice it's really good they
look great they look happy my potatoes
are chirping they're making little
crispy potato stems honestly
confidence level is maybe an 8.5 maybe a
9 maybe it's a 9 I'm gonna make a really
simple marinade for my skirt steak some
garlic oil salt I thought skirt steak
because it's so thin you would be pretty
easy to cook in the toaster oven for the
steak I'm going to try and broil it
timer for 5 minutes
it's definitely cooking looks a tiny bit
gray
I mean grainy isn't super appealing to
me let me just check the cook on this I
mean it looks really good
skirt steak is so thin it's really easy
to overcook so you want it to be pink in
the middle
ah it's a touch chewy
the flavor is really good it's just that
the Meyer reaction creates this crust
it creates the flavor and it's just kind
of gray right now what okay what if I
put a cast iron pan pre heated it in
here and then cook the steak in the cast
iron it's gonna test it on another piece
of steak and we'll see what happens it's
oh it's actually like starting to smoke
which might be good for me so I'm just
gonna put the steak right on okay this
is boudin very well oh man didn't do
anything no some help made it to here
what am I gonna do my confidence level
on the steak it is like a five good
flavor
bad texture new idea I'm going to take
the rack from another toaster oven put
it on the second slot put the tray
underneath and then put the steak
directly on the rack no matter what
happens with this round have to make it
work I really don't want to serve rubber
steak but if I have to cover it with a
lot of compound butter okay I think my
steak is done oh it's so weird you know
it's not the prettiest thing I've ever
made that's for sure I think this is as
good as it's gonna get though and I have
to move on so I'm just gonna go and let
this rest on the side I still love the
toaster oven but I guess it can't do
everything so for my appetizer I'm going
to do a baked calamari normally I would
deep-fry this and get it really crispy
delicious
you know dip a bowl I'm not sure
that's gonna happen in a toaster oven
but we'll see if I can get something
close to it I've got some mixed calamari
tubes and tentacles I know that people
can get really freaked out by the
tentacles but it's part of the animal
I'm gonna dip it in flour first then egg
and then panko after my steak snafu my
confidence level is is Gwendoline right
now okay moment of truth
I have it at 450 which is the highest
that this toaster oven goes and I'm
gonna give it five ten minutes I imagine
will be closer to ten but I've never
baked calamari before so looks a little
weird calmer ilex crispy in some places
it doesn't exactly look fried but baked
calamari not a thing for a reason I'm
gonna move on to my holy so I'm just
grating some garlic into some egg yolks
add a bit of mustard which is gonna help
emulsify it a little salt whisk to
combine so the trick with making an
aioli is to go drop by drop if you add
too much oil to begin with it's never
going to form an emulsion and it's gonna
break and be loose you want it to be
like thick and Dibble I mean like
literally a drop and whisk
[Music]
that's a lemon juice it's beautiful
[Music]
it's really good let's say
this is not good dense chewy flavorless
all three of us so my guests multiple
are on the way and so I've gotta start
plating and hope for the best
I feel like I started really strong here
and honestly just plummeted starting hi
I'm Claudia and I'm Adam and back in the
day 2015 when tasty just started Adam
and I were two of the original producers
before it's the tasty kitchens that you
guys know today we were cooking in the
original BuzzFeed Studios which did not
have an oven or a stove so we were
relying on hot plates microwave toaster
oven alexis has cooked with a lot of
crazy stuff in the past so I'm really
excited to see what she's made for us
today
I am as ready as I'll ever be
good to see you huh how'd it go you know
I'll let you be the judge of that
of course number one we've got baked
calamari and aioli so it's baked yes let
me I dunked it in mayonnaise okay so
more exciting than baked calamari we've
got and combat butter and crispy
potatoes it looks amazing
taters look auspiciously really good hmm
unfair that whatever you use your evil
make this meal I kind of forgot where
it's supposed to be guessing what the
appliances that I'm like to sit yeah I
miss into the meal now this is how it
would look
yeah I got the proper tools right on a
scale of 1 to 10 how would you rate this
object
solid eight yeah much words lady Oh
strawberry shortcake
he's a master in berries some hand
whipped cream and your very own Oh
strawberry shortcake
is made with what appliance what
appliance do you think well everything
so well browned and like cooked you did
use an iron one time though and that
looked pretty damn good I would not have
guessed that in a million years
lawnmower
definitely longer like a toaster like a
slotted toaster you're not far off
autumn I chose this toaster oven ah okay
that's impressive I love that because I
used to make a lot of early tasty stuff
and like I have always after doing that
been a proponent of like if you have a
hot plate a toaster oven you can do
anything I mean it would be concerning
if it was just as good as if you didn't
have all right Oh Oh get a to-go box
that was amazing congratulations oh it's
so kind I did it Adam and Claudia were
so generous with their feedback they
were so encouraging and supportive they
seemed to like everything I made so you
know my takeaway is that I am my own
worst critic and I feel excited for the
rest of the season for whatever else
you're gonna throw at me if you make
anything in a toaster oven
tag me I'd love to see what you can do
and comment below - guess what appliance
is gonna be next
[Music]
I feel good out of my helmet without the
real partner problem
this feels fear that would derail this
entire thing
[Music]
welcome back to chef's out of water I'm
Alexis and I'm a chef who's always up
for a challenge I've taken to the
Internet to see what appliance I should
use to make a three-course meal at the
end I'll have a surprise guest come on
and they'll try to guess what I used a
blender do I get anything else this is
going to take some extra creativity okay
here's my game plan I'm going to make a
three-course raw meal because clearly I
can't cook me with this but I think I
can make something pretty good and
pretty exciting nonetheless for dessert
today I'm making a dark chocolate mousse
it's gonna be an a learning experience
for both of us first I'm going to chop
my chocolate problem the chocolates not
gonna melt in the blender if I was doing
this you know with the stove I would use
a double boiler might even use the
microwave but I can't do that okay this
is kind of crazy but if it's a really
hot summer day in Los Angeles I wonder
if I'd put the chocolate outside in a
bowl if it'll melt this is so weird
for the appetizer I'm going to make a
raw walnut spread
I've never made anything like this so
I'm not really sure what to expect I'm
not sure about the consistency the
flavors heat brings out flavor which I
don't have the luxury of using so I need
to add flavor with other ingredients
first off I've been soaking walnuts for
a little while the soaking them is just
gonna make them more creamy or easy to
blend I guess I'm gonna start with
adding some walnuts some fresh herbs got
some sage rosemary parsley some olive
oil some nutritional yeast nutritional
yeast is just dehydrated yeast it adds
this really kind of like a nutty savory
flavor a lot of diets use it as a
replacement for cheese or like a cheesy
flavor sometimes it's called Nuge too
little vinegar I also thought some soy
sauce could be interesting just add some
complexity
[Music]
smells kind of like a natural food shop
feel like it needs more liquid it needs
something to make it more of more
spreadable water
[Music]
I need some work or water
you can see that it's starting to get
really creamy and all rest at the bottom
the top isn't there yet but this feels
like the texture I want like something
smooth typical something like pate
typically pate is made out of liver and
it has a really smooth buttery
consistency I don't think I can get a
white to that degree but I'd like to get
it more on a dipper Bowl
[Music]
and I think this is as good as it's
gonna get
I'm curious to see how it is when it
sets up after tasting this pate I feel
like in that a7 right now I feel pretty
confident it's good a little weird but
it's good
look at God this actually worked it's
not perfect throw some chunks but I
think it's gonna work
avocado for creaminess I'm gonna add
some coconut cream from the top also
some coconut oil little vanilla pinch of
salt
my son melted chocolate look at that
that's pretty melty
I'm gonna add half a banana just to add
a little more creaminess a splash of
maple syrup
it's delicious I'm going to put the
mousse in these little ramekins to chill
for a few hours so they'll get set up in
a mousse like and then I can move on
for my entree I'm going to make a raw
lasagne going to use the zucchini as
noodles and make a pesto make a
sun-dried tomato spread and a cashew
ricotta I've never done any of those
things but I have had lots of real azan
yes so you know we'll see how it goes
I'm gonna thinly slice the zucchini and
then let them sit out and sprinkle them
with salt to draw out some moisture
it'll also add some flavor to the
zucchini which honestly they need
because it's wrong so I'm gonna put this
off to the side and move on to making my
been soaking these cashews for a while
again that's just to make them really
creamy
Wow the cashews feel really oh my god
they're so soft I think it's gonna be
pretty creamy so for the nut pate I
think I did about two tablespoons and
also I think I can be pretty generous
with this especially if I'm trying to
emulate cheese I feel it kind of out of
my element not because of the blender
but just because I'm making food that I
don't normally make
and using flavors and ingredients that I
don't normally use hmm
I don't you a lot of nut based cheese's
but this is what they look like you know
it doesn't totally look like ricotta but
I think once it's layered with the other
components it's gonna kind of like blend
right in next step is my pesto
traditionally pesto is made in a mortar
and pestle
but blender totally fine I'm adding a
bunch of basil garlic this is a pretty
big clove so just gonna do half for now
pine nuts and then
[Music]
right great okay it's really lucky for
them that it is all raw and so far
hasn't had dairy great since we're going
dairy-free
that means no parmesan I'm going to use
nooch as a replacement for the parm
they'll give that umami nutty kind of
savory flavor
[Music]
it's delicious I'm gonna raise my
confidence level to an eight
the last component of my lasagna is the
tomato sauce so I'm gonna have some raw
tomato some sun-dried tomato garlic
olive oil
oh it works it looks really good
[Music]
I think this sauce is ready I can start
assembling I think I'm gonna do two next
to each other I'll start with a layer of
the tomato zucchini on top and then I
think cheese I think this looks really
pretty I actually think I would serve
this at a dinner the layers on the side
are so blue Wow wow this is really cool
I feel like I feel like a proud mom this
is my this is my baby Wow
my dark chocolate mousse has set really
well you can totally set just gonna add
some dark chocolate shavings maybe some
salt some strawberries on the side
simple elegant rustic last step for
plating is my walnut pate it's some
olive oil salt Wow okay this looks great
I'm really excited to see if the taste
tester can guess what appliance I used
let's find out hello my name is merle i
was a tasty producer for quite a few
years and now I'm a video producer
forgetful I was a voracious meat-eater
for most of my life and I've been
vegetarian for four years now and vegan
for one year now fun fact about me I can
juggle so I'm about to try the three
courses that Alexis made for me and I
really hope that I can guess what the
secret appliance is I feel like I can oh
[Music]
this is a gift so good to see you think
of everyone who could be eating this
meal Wow cool of course what counts like
pate but you wouldn't do that obviously
this is a dairy-free treatment so you
want safety cool chives Wow punchi
punchi
acid really brightens with time holy
moly Wow I feel like very wealthy this
is raw lasagna which is my pride and joy
I feel so excited it's so beautiful also
it's meat free it's dairy free Oh bless
you
[Music]
tonight right - and it's unbelievable -
soft dude is this so good what is the
sauces of sun-dried tomatoes yeah
and for dessert a dark chocolate mousse
which is also dairy-free banish'd truly
five-star yelp review get it post mints
to me so Merl final question what do you
think I've made these three dishes with
one of Mines I'm gonna say this because
it's been with me in the back of my mind
all day
is it a blender you did it you didn't do
anything we did that one better than I
could have ever imagined you know this
morning I felt kind of ambivalent
unenthusiastic and you know this day
totally turned around I feel like I
learned so much about what you can do
the blender about raw food I feel like I
feel really inspired I feel like my
creativity is kind of flowing if you
make anything really cool and really
unusual in a blender tag me on instagram
let me know internet if you thought you
had me with the blender but turned out
to be a win what do you think's in store
comment below
[Music]
I have to be honest I don't know what to
do the technology is getting in the way
of cooking okay
[Music]
welcome back to chef's out of water I'm
Alexis your chef who is always up for a
challenge that's why I've taken to the
internet for you to decide what I should
cook with next at the end a surprise
guest will come on and they'll have to
guess what I use to make the meal I
don't know who I'm cooking for and they
don't know what I'm using so let's see
what's next
okay okay these are like the most basic
rice cookers on the planet but this
feels fine you know if I could make it
work with a blender I think I can make
it work with a rice cooker
of course I've used a rice cooker to
make rice before but never anything else
I've got a lot of questions do I get
research yeah great so it turns out
people make all sorts of things with
rice cookers there's cakes there's
curries they're sauces I feel like
there's a lot of possibilities here
little rice cup some spoon steamer
I think this is gonna be really
interesting that I only has two features
which are cook and warm if I can get the
bottom heated and use it to saute things
the world is my oyster I feel like I'm
ready to go my confidence level today is
actually like an 8.5 am I gonna kick
myself for saying that I'm gonna start
off with dessert I'm going to try to
make a chocolate cake today I think the
first thing I need to do is put it on
there's not really an honor off button
it's just plugging it in which feels
pretty dangerous no idea how long it
takes to preheat but I'll let that go
got some room temperature butter brown
sugar white sugar eggs
Vennela I'm gonna add some yogurt which
I know feels a little out there but it's
just adding more fat flour cocoa powder
baking powder this is all very standard
again this is all gonna be by hand
because I'm not allowed to use anything
else rice cookers are basically steam so
it'll be more like a steamed cake than a
baked cake so I'm hoping it can be
really light and fluffy but I don't know
what temperature this gets to I don't
know how consistent the heat is so it
all feels a bit vague cake ready I'm
gonna grease this down but to prevent a
sticking that I'm gonna put parchment on
the bottom - fancy trick time to get a
perfect circle take a piece of parchment
bigger than your surface fold it over
like this and then you put it over your
bowl and you just cut like this circle
the pot is hot so cake batter in the
rice cooker this feels very weird
this cake usually takes about 35 minutes
I have absolutely no idea how long it's
gonna take but I'm just gonna keep an
eye on it and move on to my next course
chicken and potatoes classic this
actually isn't a chicken it's a Cornish
game hen because this is so small a
chicken wasn't gonna fit inside I'm
gonna try to get some color from the
bottom but just in case I can't get like
a crispy skin I thought doing like some
paprika rub would help give it some
color
I've got paprika cumin coriander salt
pepper it's beautiful great color okay
something concerning the rice cooker is
switched from cook to warm and when I
press cook it just goes to warm every
time it switches to warm I need to take
the entire thing out unplug it replug it
and put it back in switch it to cook
this definitely derails my plan a bit
with in terms of cooking and consistency
since clearly it's not gonna go for more
than a few minutes we're just cutting
some aromatics right now to add some
flavor to the base of the chicken oh
this is gonna be a long day
this barely fits now it's making the
right sound the chicken smells amazing
it sounds right it smells right I'm
gonna give it a flip wow this is
gorgeous
I'm just gonna get a little more color
on oh this is switch to warm to her I
have to be honest I don't know what to
do
I can't cook a chicken in a warming vent
it feels like something's wrong with
this machine it can't be me I know about
machines so my chicken got browned but
the machine keeps going on and off we've
looked at Amazon reviews did a lot more
research on the internet and I think it
just needs more moisture so onions are
going in garlic have some flavor
this cake is cooking it's not fully
cooked yet but
[Music]
it's quite good okay new plan
I'm gonna make another cake batter
that's a little more moist steam it in
the steamer basket put in water below
keep switching it on and off it is
cooking so I think I just need to be
really diligent this feels like a little
out of sorts but my confidence level is
still pretty high I would say I'm at a
seven right now I thought this was gonna
be such an easy one I was like rice
cooker no problem some problems so the
cake looks like it's actually staying on
cook which i think is because of the
water in the base I think for the
chicken I need to get it back to cook
and then cook it with some white wine so
that it adds more moisture it smells
absolutely incredible okay so I've got
my onions my garlic my chicken and wine
it's on cook lid on we wait I was
thinking like do I serve this as a whole
hen like a little cube hen my cake looks
wild but it's definitely cooking the day
started off with a few snafus but I
think we're back I think I figured out
the power if I can just keep the heat on
and consistent I'm golden you know it
doesn't have that crispy skin because it
was kind of like in liquid kind of
poaching but there's some browning it's
quite pretty this is gorgeous there's
like all this sauciness it's garlicky
oniony I'm gonna try to just cook it
down for a few more minutes as long as
the cook is gonna stay on
[Music]
it's divine like you could just dip
bread in this and call it a day
now that my chickens done I'm gonna get
my potatoes ready the steamer basket
worked with cake
with potatoes it makes even more sense
so try it potatoes going cake
maybe we should be steaming cakes more
often feels really good that was like
pretty painless
[Music]
looks like my potatoes are nearly ready
I'm just gonna heat some milk and heavy
cream some rosemary I have a whole head
of garlic that I crushed I'm just gonna
get that warmed up so it'll get really
confused and I'm gonna incorporate that
into the mashed potatoes got a potato
ricer which is a tool but it's not a
mechanical tool so I think it's okay to
use it's just like my favorite thing in
the world to do it's so weird oh my god
I love it looks so beautiful these
potatoes are gorgeous if I had a better
rice cooker I think this would be
actually pretty effective because the
rice cooker doesn't have a lot of power
it took honestly like 40 minutes for the
potatoes to put some tinder and they
could have been tender in like 10
minutes on the stove but the result is
great okay my milk and cream mixture
looks like it's ready
oh it's actually boiling damn oh my god
it smells so good if you dumped all of
the milk and cream in here it would just
become like a gloopy mess but if you do
it bit by bit
it'll get absorbed into the potatoes
they're so good oh my god
my confidence level if it's about these
potatoes 10 my chocolate cake is cool it
looks kind of like a brain it's got all
these really weird ripples anyway I'm
gonna make a chocolate frosting and I
thought I could melt some chocolate in
the steamer basket I'm gonna treat the
rice cooker as if it was a double boiler
so that means water in the bottom I also
have mini chocolate chips because I
thought they wouldn't melt faster I'm
gonna make the base of the frosting
while the chocolate melts so this would
be about a billion times easier with a
hand mixer or a stand mixer but you know
the drill I've got really soft butter
vanilla
little bit of cream oh this is gonna be
a pain oh no I'm gonna take my cold cake
and I'm gonna cut out three mini cakes
and kind of make like a mini chocolate
I'm gonna make a mini
chocolate layer cake okay if I stack
three of them that looks absolutely
crazy but I could cut them in half and
do thinner layers hey I can make a four
layer cake this is so fun the chocolates
good it's only right to try the frosting
with again
[Music]
this looks ridiculous for looks crazy
but go big or go home I think I'm gonna
lean into the rustic look and put some
berries around it to serve finally a
dish that makes sense for a rice cooker
I'm going to make mussels in white wine
super-easy
mussels are in so many fancy restaurants
I think it's definitely something people
associate with higher price tag but the
whole joke is that mussels are actually
super inexpensive they're one of the
most affordable seafood options and
they're so easy to make I thought I
would make the broth in the base and
then put the mussels in the steamer
basket on top onions garlic pepper
flakes white wine I want the alcohol to
be cooked out of this and just have the
flavor of the wine you don't need much
to give mussels such an incredible
flavor the taste sets are better like
mussels that would be so sad my broth is
ready I'm just going to add the steamer
basket right on top let cook them until
they open so it should be a few minutes
moment of truth
wow they're so pretty
oh this broth looks so good I just added
some lemon adding parsley it looks
absolutely perfect can I be the taste
tester I'm so excited
honestly confidence level 10 I'm ready
hi I'm Ryan I'm a video producer at
BuzzFeed I make branded content my
favorite food is sushi my least
favourite food is my mother's Brussels
sprouts I cook out of necessity I don't
cook for pleasure like last night I had
plain chicken and plain pasta and I ate
it in the dark alexis has made a
three-course meal for me with a mystery
appliance I don't know what the
appliance is but I'm going to try and
guess
okay you know what bring them in such a
treat hi I'm a tree you're a tree you're
a tree are you ready I am are you I am
about a level 10 right now so I am so
ready ten out of ten out of ten for your
first course you have mussels in white
wine
very nice stay like mussels I love
muscles okay cool cool cool that's great
they're cooked well I am gonna take that
as a win
yeah of course of course it's a great oh
my god to stop you don't you can keep
going right oh my god I'm so glad you're
hungry because this is a Cornish game
hen we got a little smaller over some
sautéed onions and mashed potatoes I
just can't talk right oh I'll give it a
try okay go ahead
mmm this is so good that is well
seasoned
mmm this is probably like a $30 meal
thank you whoa so for dessert you have
your own mini chocolate cake
[Music]
what do you think I use to make this
meal had there had to be enough heat to
get this crust and like this get a
curling iron no rice wait you already
did a rice cooker no or did you did you
raise a bathtub when you said rice
cooker before you were right I was right
Wow does that make this more or less
impressive Oh totally impressive it ups
the wow factor
thank you very much you're so up this is
a treat and I'm gonna go now probably
gonna take some food with me take
whatever you want
awesome I'm gonna spill for sure oh I
like the combination cake and mussels
yeah yeah it balances out bye-bye
I'm so glad he liked it honestly it was
really really good like after the
blender after today I'm feeling good and
really confident whatever is next I'm
ready comment below to let me know what
you've made in a rice cooker
[Music]
oh I'm the chef that loves challenge
this is a toy the marshmallow fix clip
welcome back to chef's out of water I'm
Alexis a chef who's always up for a
challenge that's why I've taken to the
internet for you to decide what I should
cook with next at the end there'll be a
surprise guest who will have to guess
what I used to make the meal I don't
know who I'm cooking for and they don't
know what appliance I'm using so let's
get to it an easy bake oven this is
crazy there's there's like not even a
full inch of space my hand is bigger
than this tray this is this is a joke as
a kid I dreamt about having an easy bake
oven and now my dream is my nightmare Oh
No okay it's gonna be fine I think I
have a plan we'll see if it works before
the first course I'm going to make a
personal pizza to make it really
delicious I'm gonna start off making my
own dough so I've got my warm water I
just sprinkle some yeast over it and let
it bloom meantime I'm gonna whisk my
sugar salt and olive oil this is gonna
be a really simple quick get the dough
you can tell when these blooming because
still start to bubble a little yeast
looks foamy and good gonna add that to
the oil and adding the flour I just had
the thought that pizza usually cooks a
really really high temperatures the
internet told me this only gets to 350
so
pizza dough might be a bad idea maybe if
I rolled the dough out super thin I let
this rise in this oiled bowl while my
pizza dough Rises I'm gonna get started
on my next course because it's gonna
take a long time for my next course I'm
going to do nachos I had this idea that
I could make my own tortilla chips by
just cutting the tortillas brushing them
with oil and hopefully they'll crisp up
and the Easy Bake Oven let's see how
this goes
I'm gonna add some spices to my grand
beef some salt garlic powder onion
powder chili powder paprika and I guess
I'll just mix it ground beef needs to
cook to 160 degrees so it should be able
to work in here I just don't know how
long it'll take and again I don't think
it's gonna get that browning I have a
feeling that might be kind of gray I'm
gonna check on these guys oh okay it's
not quite there but it's actually kind
of working like there's some crispy yes
here okay but here's the thing it's
gonna take me like three hours just to
make chips is there any way that I can
have some help oh my sous-chef turns out
to be my best friend yeah and I got one
too okay so the first step we have to
preheat it okay so oh I know this is
crazy
mm-hmm but we have to do it like two
chips at a time I think well I work on
chips I'll have you work on ground beef
okay I really want to use this I mean
how crispy do you need chips to be
really you know what I think we can
pivot to many tacos
that's cool I think it's time to check
oh it's like oh wait can I can do oh
okay Wow okay this is this is kind of
good I know I'm shocked okay we have a
long way to go um but I think if you
keep doing the beat yeah it'll be good
okay I'm gonna cut out some mini
tortillas from the big boot because this
doesn't fit in the slot but this does so
so we wait yeah okay wait this is
actually this is like a chip why is that
so much better I don't know okay I'm
gonna stick a mattress this one goes
back you're getting so good at this huh
beautiful I have two chips
that looks great well your beef Wow
we've done we've done one thing so we've
got two in here one in here so we're
actually almost a ton it should only
take 25 minutes for the personal one
that's awesome okay if you can remove
the casein and crumble it up I'm gonna
do it the same way that the ground beef
you're thinking of such pepper onion
pizza feels a little ambitious now but I
think the pepper and onion can just be
full kind of roast oh wait oh this is
smoking Oh
one very crispy chip you know it's fine
fine it'll be on the bottom of the pile
some people that would be their favorite
job yeah those are beautiful
chips love it I'm gonna do nine chips
that peels sufficient oh wow this dough
is Wow
it's feisty she's doing well I think
we're coming to the part of nervous
about okay you can get that cookie and
stamp out two circles circles
okay can you check the sausage I bet
it's done do you think it's also just
ready whoa yeah
amazing amazing it's like a real pizza
here I'll check this my confidence level
about the pizza is a seven oh you know
I'm happy for you gladly I just took
these onions out we have it actually
looks it looks really good that's good -
it smells like very doughy okay okay
these look these look amazing
I mean this is yeah Wow oh my god the
bottom has some Browns there I mean the
smells it smells amazing it's it's kind
of more like focaccia than pizza but
it's very it's fine I think I have it
from here thank you so much no way to
see Ryan was the biggest help I could
have ever asked for this time to start
plating
this is pre-made sauce I've got some
mozzarella and some of my toppings I'm
so excited for this person to guess what
I used like they're gonna have no idea
this is actually really fun
I made a mini pizza with real pizza
dough in an easy-bake oven making food
with the kids joy is so out of my
element but I feel elated
there was a cheese pool did you see it
one of my finger after school's knives
was cookies every single day so this
this definitely needs a sweet element so
I'm gonna make a crispy rice Zac I'm
just gonna cut some marshmallows some
butter got my marshmallows on and pop
them in I'm gonna layer the nachos with
obviously chips cheese my ground beef
got some black beans tomatoes and
avocado
[Music]
Oh
it seems to be a bit of a marshmallow
explosion okay okay fine fine fine
pressure this I feel better about this
this looks good can add chocolate chips
I'm gonna go find a cookie cutter and
like put this into a keychain oh my god
this is so cute okay I've been told that
the taste testers here and they're ready
to try and I can't wait to see if they
can guess what I've used my name is
Jonas and I'm nine years old the first
time Alexis cooked for me was on Hydra
you cook robot episodes we heard you
really like robots next we actually love
it I think it looks so weird and cool
the cookie dish that's mine today
Alexis made three snacks for me and I
have to guess what she used to make
I'm so proud of everything I made and I
can't wait to see what this taste tester
thanks let's bring out something wow
it's so good to see you again
you team how's it going getting for your
first after-school snack you have nachos
like that oh great
on a scale of one to ten what would you
give these nachos an eight great I'll
take it
you've got mini pizzas with sausage
pepper and onion just tastes like pizza
yeah yeah maybe the crust would be a
little hard I think that's a fair
assessment on a scale of one to ten what
would you give this Pizza snakes fair
are you ready for your last note you go
again a ten okay so we've got an eight a
six and A ten I think that's pretty good
I like that is it that you put tomato oh
you don't like tomato and remember
tomato and this was kind of hard to eat
like to bite it off mmm as you can see
okay so now that you've tried all three
snacks what do you think I used to make
them a pan
valiant valiant choice oh I know a
rolling pin for the mid oh I definitely
used a rolling pin what do you think I
used to cook it stove
oh we know I'm on it okay well I've got
some news for you
I basically used a kid's toy to make all
three of these no I did it
you used a kid's toy ha ha this is what
I used to make this I am so impressed
with this [ __ ] Thank You Otis
I did make a fatal mistake of not
actually trying the chips oh they're
really hard I still make chips in an
easy-bake oven ok the chips are fairly
inedible
but overall I think this day was such a
success I feel so proud and excited and
I just had absolutely no idea that any
of this is possible and you know I know
I said Easy Bake Ovens were a nightmare
but I think I just fulfilled a childhood
fantasy comment below and let me know
what you make in your Easy Bake Ovens
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to chef's out of water I'm
Alexis and I'm a chef who's always up
for a challenge that's why I've taken to
the Internet to decide what I should
cook with today I don't know who I'm
cooking for and they don't know what I'm
gonna use so let's see what's in this
box
this feels like a personal attack you
know last time when I used a microwave
it didn't go exactly as planned per se
oh my god
I honestly like I this is a disaster I'm
really hoping to redeem myself this time
and make something that I'm actually
proud of do I at least get researched
this time better than research hi Alexis
and tasty I'm Gemma Stafford a
professional chef a cookbook author and
the host of the online baking show
bigger bolder baking now although I'm
professionally trained chef I do know a
thing or two about cooking in the
microwave some of my most famous recipes
have been a pizza in a mug a 3 layer
cake in the microwave and even a whole
batch of brownies made in the microwave
okay these look amazing I didn't even
know that was possible
Alexis here are some of my microwave
tips to get you through this challenge
successfully tip number one err on the
side of caution when it comes to your
timing start out with around 2 to 3
minutes on the clock
then check in the microwave and if you
need more time after that 2 shorter
increments I think that's one of the
biggest takeaways from last time is I
was doing really long increments and
stuff was catching on fire tip number 2
microwave on full power personally I
don't use any of the settings on my
microwave if you follow tip number one
you'll be more in control of the time
and less likely to set the place on fire
I feel really comforted that Gemma
doesn't use different voltages it feels
kind of intimidating to me and
she doesn't I don't need to do it either
okay tip number three Alexis stay close
to the microwave when it's on I watched
your previous challenge and you went all
the way around the kitchen when you put
something in there stay close by so you
can keep an eye on it and you're less
likely to have anything go wrong okay I
think this is just a good tip for being
in the kitchen I should know better
Alexis I wish you the very best of luck
and don't burn the place down she seems
to believe in me I have a second shot I
think I can do this instead of a
traditional three-course meal I'm gonna
do three different brunch items
three-course brunch one surprised taste
tester and one microwave let's see if I
can do this I'm going to start off with
a quiche how bad can it go I'm gonna try
to make a crust for the quiche I know
there's a lot of like crustless quiche
in a microwave but again I want to try
to elevate this I want to try to make it
a little more advanced last time I did
burn the crust of my lemon bars might
have caught on fire but I'm gonna listen
to Gemma's advice and go really slowly
this is gonna be a really standard crust
got my flour pinch of salt stir it all
around easy it's really important that
the butter stays cold again cold dairy
equals a flaky crust once the butter is
all in then you can start using your
hands to start breaking it apart I'm
using ice water you could also use apple
cider vinegar some people use vodka just
helps make the dough a bit more tender
so I'm just gonna shape these into two
disks wrap them in plastic wrap they
should chill for about an hour
especially because it's so hot here
I want the dough to be firm so it can
roll out to the fridge so I've got one
of my chilled dough disks whoo she's
tender Wow see those pads of butter that
means super flaky and the butter yes I
do
I love butter how about you another very
cool trick if you want to transport your
dough you can just roll it like this oh
my God look how cool this is
and then you can just put it right back
on
we go like that magic so my dough feels
really soft right now just because it's
getting so hot from the light so I'm
actually going to just chill it for
maybe five minutes while my crust chills
I'm going to cook off some bacon five
minutes with a paper towel but also
Gemma said did not do anything more than
two minutes so I'm going to do two
minutes and then increments after that
look at me learn that was seven minutes
honestly it looks good there's still a
few parts that aren't super crispy but
it's gonna be baked again in the quiche
so I think it's fine it's pretty good so
much less rubbery than last time
so I've just got some eggs here gonna
beat the eggs with some milk heavy cream
add a pinch of salt cheese bacon if I
was making this quiche at home I would
be doing everything exactly the same up
until this point part baking is when you
bake a crust by itself first put
parchment paper down and then put
something like beans some people use pie
weights you want to make sure that the
pie weights are smooth it in an even
layer otherwise you're gonna get some
burning underneath I'm gonna start with
two minutes goodbye god I hope this
works
I think we're filming on the hottest
week of summer it's certainly a heat
wave right now and there's no a/c in
this room you're welcome
I've been doing this for about 15
minutes
okay the edges are pretty pale but the
center is getting brown the edges of the
crust definitely need more time but I
think I just have to put the eggs in and
see what happens otherwise the bottom is
gonna be scorched so
I mean this looks great really really
really want this torque I'm not gonna
walk away I'm gonna just sit right here
with this hob microwave and babysit my
quiche
let's take a look at this this is very
weird it smells great the quiche needs
more time the crust is still pretty pale
back and it goes okay
I'm just gonna try it I'm gonna open it
it's pretty weird but I just the crust
is like not cooked I'm gonna let it come
to room temperature I'm gonna try a
slice if it needs to be cooked tomorrow
I will reevaluate
moving on I'm going to make super fluffy
banana chocolate chip pancakes actually
developed this recipe for tasty 101
they're legitimately the best pancakes
I've ever had but I've never made them
in a microwave so we'll see so I've got
some flour a few tablespoons of sugar
pinch of salt baking powder and baking
soda I've got my milk melted butter
I also separated the yolks and the
whites for the eggs
helps them be really fluffy with pancake
batter you actually want to leave it on
the clumpy er side and actually see some
pockets of flour it's gonna help it make
it really fluffy then add the egg whites
you just want to stir until the egg
whites are just combined I'm gonna do
test without the banana and chocolate
chips first because I don't know how
long this cooks and I don't want to be
wasteful spray down a microwave-safe
plate and then add some lumpy batter
the pancakes have spread all over the
plate so I think I need to use a smaller
plate or I need to use something that
can be like a like a mold a mold for the
pancake there's literally no one on the
planet who wants to eat this it's not
that bad
Wow okay okay so I got a few different
vessels I thought it could be fun to try
a ramekin first and put a little scoop
batter in also gonna do two minutes
straight off huh okay to me this looks
kind of like a little cake more so than
a pancake let me just see if this one
with the lips will help okay
doesn't look beautiful but that's okay
don't judge a book by its character
don't judge a book by its character
cover well yes they you just getting to
me
honestly I think it's as good as it's
gonna get I want to serve them with some
fruits and syrup on the side I think
there's a few of them it'll make them a
bit more appealing voila
they're not totally browned they're not
really fluffy but it's pretty cute I
think I'm ready to move on to my final
course so far things are going pretty
well I think my confidence is at a seven
solid seven for my final course I'm
going to try to make Eggs Benedict
traditionally Eggs Benedict is over
Canadian bacon on an English muffin
poached egg on top I don't really like
Canadian bacon so I'm gonna use
prosciutto it sorry Canada I'm gonna
cook it just the same way I did the
bacon it's already cured it doesn't need
to be cooked I just thought it'd be nice
to get some like Chris penis two minutes
crispy prosciutto Wow that was the
easiest thing I've ever done so I've got
some eggs here I'm gonna pour some water
over it and add a little bit of acid 30
seconds two minutes a minute a minute
I'm gonna do a minute oh I mean it did
kind of pump in [ __ ] I need to clean
this up and I'm gonna try again
so that was a bust to say I'm gonna omit
the lemon juice this time and go in
30-second intervals that feels better
oh okay it's working it's working very
slowly
look at this Oh poached egg this is
amazing this is amazing this is amazing
okay here's the thing here's the thing
it's still cooked a little too far but I
think if I do like 15 seconds and then
another 15 seconds for the last egg
it'll be perfect
no lemon juice a little less time
poached eggs are happening this is not
perfect but look at that weird egg why
did that happen
this is the problem microwaves
inconsistency I think I need to get a
few more eggs what in the hell is
happening I thought he just figured it
out
why is it doing this you know what I
think we need bigger bowls we I I need
bigger bowls maybe more water too and
you know what back to the lemon juice
taking it out kind of looks like an egg
ghost this is beautiful a little weird
but pretty good I'm gonna do one more
egg hopefully it works I've been told my
surprise guest is 15 minutes away so I'm
gonna finish this egg up move on to the
hollandaise and get plating so I've got
my egg yolks lemon juice salt pinch of
cayenne and then I'm gonna strain the
melted butter and give it a stir pop it
in the microwave and I think 30 seconds
whoa whoa it's not the worst hollandaise
I've ever had it's fine it's totally
fine
hollandaise on top whoa damn she think
I'm just gonna add a few chives to shock
anyone but a little flaky Cecil
okay I think we're ready for the taste
test what a weird day
it's me Gemma Stafford from bigger
bolder baking I'm here in the tasty
kitchen to see what Alexis has come up
with today I have a feeling Alexis went
pretty ambitious what she made in the
first video I'm sure she tried to stop
that and maybe she learned a thing or
two so I'm hoping it's going to be a
step above thank you I mean more helpful
than any research I could have done I
have to say your first attempt was like
really ambitious like such ballsy but
you know you learn from your mistakes
I'm hoping that you improved on it for
today hey let's get started
so for brunch number one it's a bacon
and Gruyere quiche oh my gosh I love
quiche did you do the pastry in the
microwave
I did my gosh she's crispy what's
amazing
you actually have layers in your pastry
that's amazing
thank you of course two is Eggs Benedict
it's with crispy prosciutto instead of
Canadian bacon because it's fancy is
this really good flavor and I have to
commend you the fact that your
hollandaise is pretty rockin and it
didn't split the hollandaise is a win ya
know that that's really awesome I think
he nails us and the crispy prosciutto
okay so these third oh my gosh chocolate
chip banana pancakes
that is awesome they're not like regular
pancakes obviously but for a microwave I
feel pretty proud okay you tasted these
I did it is on the drier side it's on
the drier side yep your strawberries are
really good I worked very hard on this I
think there's some things that like copy
Beach I think that's like pancakes from
a griddle completely agree I have to say
you absolutely would have fooled me but
these other two I think you came to
compare it to the first video and to
here I think you're you're moving up in
the microwave but we're not gonna do the
pancakes okay
I think you did awesome and you know
what you did so good I have a little
present for you so this is a bigger
bolder baking bug specifically for
making mug meals it okay I could have
used this like eight hours ago you guys
done all of it in this bowl see it's a
spork and it comes in the handle see it
you mix everything microwave eases
you're good to go
thank you this is for you so I'm just
gonna take this I feel so good I feel
elated I feel so proud of myself
this was such a wild day there were
peaks there were valleys but ultimately
I think I redeemed myself with the
microwave what's next this another
present okay what am I gonna do in the
blindfold this is a safety hazard to
cook blindfolded oh god I think I'm
ready
[Music]
previously on chef out of water
what am I gonna do the blindfold
Oh God I think I'm ready
[Music]
welcome to the season finale of chef's
out of water I'm Alexis your chef who's
always up for a challenge all season
long the Internet has been choosing what
I should cook with and today it looks
like you've chosen where I don't know
who I'm cooking for and they don't know
what I'm cooking with although I'm
guessing they'll probably be able to
figure it out
I can smell pine needles and I hear a
babbling brook
so oh this is amazing this is my dream
all season long I've been asking for
fire and I'm gonna have fire and I'm
outside thank you so I'm gonna make a
three-course meal over a campfire I've
got to get some kindling to get started
let's go make a fire you thought you had
me with a campfire but this is actually
a gift I've been making fires for truly
as long as I can remember I grew up in
the country we have a really big
fireplace and every single night in the
winter we built a fire because it's so
cold I usually put a bunch of newspaper
crumpled up ton of kindling on top
luckily we're in the woods we have an
abundance of kindling and then make like
a kind of teepee situation around it
with the wood and as soon as it gets hot
then you can add more wood and kind of
shift it into you know having some
having direct heat so I'm having lower
heat so I'll have some more control over
the campfire I have a great to cook with
which is making it so I don't want to
say easy but
before I light this fire we need to talk
fire safety we've been working with the
Angeles National Forest
they know we're filming here there's a
ton of people on fire watch I've got
Ryan with me he's gonna be watching the
fire making sure there's no debris
anything happening let's light this fire
[Music]
well my fire is going and getting really
hot get it ready I'm gonna start on
dessert I'm making a plum cardamom
orange crumble I did a tasty 101 about
this so I feel very prepared so I'm
starting off with some plums did I
seriously just put salt I cannot be
trusted what is wrong with me yeah it
was literally just salt oh no oh no I'm
gonna go wash these thumbs off stand by
I have to stop doing that I also just
said a minute before that I was level 10
confident so I think I need to bring my
ego down about five notches and stay
away from salt
sugar flour as a binder you could use
cornstarch too orange zest you're just
mixing everything together
the plums can actually just hang out in
this skillet okay
moving on to the filling I've got flour
oats salt intentionally sugar very
intentionally cinnamon and cardamom mix
and then some cold cute butter and I'm
just gonna take my hands coorporate it
and then kind of crumble it you know I
think a challenge is going to be that I
know how long this takes in an oven or
even on a grill but over a campfire it's
gonna be a little trickier in terms of
tightening crumbles done I'm gonna wash
my hands cover this with foil and get
this on fire we've got this really great
safety gloves this fire is really hot
campfires can actually get up to over
500 degrees so I've got a ton of options
it's probably too hot for the crumble
now but I want to get it going
the flames are gonna die down a bit it
actually looks like it's at the perfect
spot for my entree I've got a few
different elements but one of them is
fire roasted eggplant where you actually
just bury it in the coals I'm gonna get
a head start doing that move on to my
prep zucchini and halloumi salad all
done over the grill of course when I use
the blender I thinly sliced zucchini on
a mandolin so I'm gonna do the same
thing will probably grow really fast but
that's okay I'm just gonna sprinkle them
with little salt this is gonna draw
moisture out just gonna slice cucumbers
easy
I'm gonna make some pickled red onions
filled with fire pickling is really easy
you basically need vinegar sugar and
salt
oh and water I'm gonna add some
peppercorns and some coriander seeds so
how this
this liquid is gonna go over the fire
I'm just gonna cut up this cheese really
really fast
ooh baby oh my god
cobbler has been taken over by the plums
but it's okay whoa okay definitely time
for tinfoil school my pickling liquid
should go on the hottest part right here
I'm just gonna get let this go for a few
minutes and my eggplant looks absolutely
perfect
I mean Oh just falling apart it's like
legit collapsed into itself which is
exactly what I want got a new set of
boobs oh my god so and you just take a
spoon and all that beautiful perfectly
cooked eggplant skin goes inside my
pickling liquid is ready to go I'm gonna
add the onions so now that the onions
are in and the pickling liquid is hot I
can actually take it off the heat and
I'll just let it rest to room
temperature this cobbler is definitely
taking longer than it would nothing but
it looks kind of cool and rustic I'm
just gonna throw some peppers on the
grill
I'm really excited about my entree I'm
gonna do this whole Mediterranean spread
so I'm gonna make lamb kofta which are
like all belong with lamb meatballs
first things first I'm gonna put garlic
in the grill - just a little bit of
olive oil wrapping it up you can just
stick this literally right in the fire
I'm gonna work on the lamb kofta so I've
got mint parsley salt some smoke I've
got everything in my bowl for my lamb
kofta and then just gonna mix it all
together my peppers are so charged so
beautiful oh my god I'm just gonna peel
the charred skin right off I was hoping
that the crumble was gonna turn golden
brown it's definitely cooked through
it's just doesn't have that classic
color it's also getting kind of jammy on
top like this jammy plum mess um so I'm
gonna take it off I think it's fine it's
not gonna be an oven crumble but it's
baked true it'll be delicious you don't
want to shape these into meatball so you
want to make them into these like oblong
an extra-large egg maybe a duck egg I'm
just gonna skewer it and my coffee are
done I have a bit more prep to do but
I'm gonna have Ryan put them on the
grill Ryan you rang if you can just put
these over the grill medium-high heat
okay this is the best I'm gonna add some
lemons the lemons I just want them to
get really charred and beautiful I'm
gonna use that for the baba ghanoush and
for a vinaigrette I'm gonna make this
kind of garlic
Kirby spread gonna grab the garlic the
garlic is a bit charred it's soft it's
just gonna add a really nice smoky
flavor to the whole spread just smash it
just like paste pepper plate cuz I'm
gonna add some green olives gonna add
some capers just add a little more
brightness I'm gonna hit it with some
olive oil I'm gonna add salt stir I'm
gonna let this Irby situation hang out
these are good oh they smell absolutely
incredible
they look like they're cooked perfectly
so we'll see once you try them
look at those lemons I'm just gonna move
them here these zucchini are super thin
so I imagine it's gonna take less than
two minutes if that gloomy bottom
halloumi is a really firm cheese so it's
pretty ideal for grilling taking lemons
oh great
they're just slightly charred which is
what I want I don't want them to fall
apart just have a little smokiness from
the girl yeah the cheese is melting a
very fast-paced hey my confidence level
in the salad is like 9 I'm gonna put
Ryan on fire watch fires nearly out and
get everything assembled
now that everything's grilled I have a
few more things to do I'm gonna actually
have fruit the fire goes down I'm gonna
have Ryan just grill these quickly Ryan
this is gonna add some of the lemon
juice to my Irby thing oh my god it's so
good okay Wow
the grilled garlic and grilled lemons
just intensify the flavors even more got
my eggplant from earlier I'm gonna add
some tahini lemon again salt this is
definitely the best campfire meal I've
ever made for the peppers see how
they've kind of collapsed into
themselves they have this amazing
charred skin and you can just peel it
right off that's a joy of a charred
pepper I thought maybe I'd make like a
platter a tray see how that goes of
course to Mediterranean plate is done so
now I'm just gonna plate this salad it's
add some mint the onions have probably
been pickling for only two or three
hours but after an hour you can use them
tiny bit of olive oil a little bit of
sumac and salt this is so pretty I'm so
happy my taste tester has arrived
and I think staying in line with the
campfire theme I'm gonna serve the
crumble just in the cast-iron I think
it's time to taste hi I'm Tony I am a
nifty producer here at BuzzFeed and I am
a huge outdoor enthusiast I used to be a
marine biologist I love camping usually
on the weekends I try to find some fun
things to do outside I'm super excited
to see what Alexis uses today cuz we are
outdoors and you know there's so many
options now we have solar ovens you have
these small little stovetop oven so
there's so many things
but I know what she's gonna make is
gonna be amazing so I'm super excited I
think this was my favorite day of the
entire season and it's the taste test
I'm most excited for so can we bring
them in thank you for having me the
perfect taste tester yay I think you are
the biggest outdoors person I know
oh yeah I mean you go skiing you go
hiking you do everything yeah well I'm
very excited to be here course one your
appetizer is a zucchini and Helene eats
out it smells good what does it smell
like to you like summer but that I feel
like summer smells like barbecue and
charcoal and it definitely comes out
course to this whole Mediterranean
spread this is like insane over the top
for at a campsite having this come out
I'm glamping yeah that's the move one of
these a Mediterranean taco wow that
looks really good and this lemon grilled
lemons are great for anything like I bet
it would be great
did you use this here Hey okay final
course Oh beauty it is I know it looks
crazy
it's a plum cardamom crumble it's almost
like a if a lemon tart was a plum tart
like the same consistency
yodeler you made a curd yogurt holy
that's exactly what it tastes like this
is so good these are the kind of
unexpected things that happen when
you're camping and now you have this
like horny masterpiece they could be
like you I made a plum tart
hey it's new thing I told me you've
probably figured it out by now but what
do you think I made this meal with
firewood great yeah yeah it's fiery you
could smell it in the food I wish you
guys could smell it cuz you could smell
that like that wood-burning grill
there's hard there's nothing else like
it there's no appliance there's no tool
there's nothing else except firewood and
campfire that can give you those flavors
thanks for trekking here and now we're
into the woods I love it it's like the
best birthday ever
what an amazing season I feel proud of
myself I feel excited I feel creatively
inspired honestly I didn't know that I
could do half of this stuff and it was
great campfire cooking was great blender
Easy Bake Oven I just I feel so lucky
that I got to do this Thank You internet
for all your suggestions your tips your
advice and even some of your crazy ideas
I'm Alexis thanks for watching the first
season of chef's out of water let me
know in the comments if you've made any
crazy campfire meals I'd love to
[Music]